d'un carnivore le premier film réalisé
par les acteurs jeremy yannick rénier
leïla bekhti hésitant en raw campent
deux soeurs en fusion est en rivalité
permanente dans leur vie personnelle et
professionnelle pour ne pas faire de
jaloux j'ai donc invité les deux
comédiennes sur le plateau de tchitchao
leïla bekhti zita en rouge très contente
de parler d'eux à carnivores jeremy et à
yannick rénier que j'ai beaucoup aimé
alors on explique c'est un film réalisé
par deux frères comédien et vous jouez
deux soeurs comédienne rival première
question évidemment est-ce que c'est
autobiographique ce que vous savez alors
autobiographique oui parce qu'on se
déteste et de deux les deux frères et ce
qu'ils ont expliqué pourquoi ils en ont
c'est pas du chipset graphique je pense
que il voulait faire un thriller un
thriller du quotidien et c'est un film
sur la fratrie sur la place de la
réussite sur l' influence que les
parents peuvent avoir et c'est surtout
une histoire d'amour parce que elles
sont un peu way rival mais elles
s'aiment fort peut-être mal trop forte
mais elle aime très fort on n'aime
jamais trop moi je pense on va pas au
bar on restera
pourquoi tu en mets ici mais je voulais
de voir une victime peut-être bien plus
perverse que son bourreau si elle est
consentante ou
chercher des victoires sur le tournage
si jamais vous ayez besoin de figures
qu'on s'a toit pour changer tu le
mérites
arrête de venir ce que je vais faire et
alors tout les deux quand vous avez reçu
le scénario ce que vous étiez à l'aise
avec cette répartition des rôles est ce
que spontanément seriez allé vers le
rôle qu'on vous a proposé
moi j'ai eu peur j'ai eu très très peur
quand j'ai reçu le ce rôle
c'est tellement loin de moi c'est
tellement c'est pas ma réalité tout ça
c'est cette rivalité a effacé d'un trait
frustré j'ai besoin d'eux quand j'aime
j'aime quand j'aime pas j'aime pas j'ai
besoin de le dire j'ai besoin d'eux et
en même temps c'est ce qui m'a amené à
dire oui tout de suite
pour moi c'est un rôle qui me faisait
peur parce que ce côté extrêmement
expansive sensuel parfois mal élevés
elle a un côté comme ça quand on l'a on
la découvre pour la première fois on se
dit en tant que jeune comédienne je veux
pas ressembler à cette personne j'ai pas
envie d'aller dans les mêmes travers etc
mais il ya énormément de composition
pour nous deux en fait dans la phase 1
et c'est ça qui est intéressant si vous
avez servir nous plaisir
il ne sommes qu'au fond
leila vous aviez dit dans une interwiew
pour télérama que vous aviez
l'impression d'être à l'essai dans tous
vos films ce manque de confiance vous a
aidés à ne rien votre personnage non
mais en fait ce que je dis c'est que on
fait un métier hyper aléatoire et je
sais que ça peut paraître trop que je
m'excuse encore d'être là quand je dis
cela mais pas du tout c'est j'aime
l'idée de deux commencent à un tournage
comme c'était le premier comme si
c'était le dernier aussi parce que parce
que je pourrais vous citer des milliers
de comédiens qui était extraordinaire il
ya dix ans et qu'on voit plus
aujourd'hui donc si ça c'est arrivé à
eux ça peut m'arriver à moi donc du coup
le jour où je serai plus émerveillé par
tout ça eh ben c'est débile a joué un
restaurant ça pourra très bien aussi
j'aimerais cuisiner eux est d'ailleurs
je vais demander toutes les deux à vos
débuts quand vous ne saviez pas encore
si vous allez réussir à faire ce métier
ce que vous êtes déjà posé la question
de du plan b bah oui oui un mois avant
moi pendant en fait récemment je me suis
dit est-ce que je deviendrai pas
policière ouais ouais ouais mais c'est
vite passé
non c'était cema c'est une question
d'envié aussi c'est que je pense qu'à un
moment je perdais un peu mon envie voilà
je me disais peut-être qu'en faisant
autre chose
elle reviendra mais en fait de de se
nourrir de lecture de plein de choses en
fait m'a permis de retrouver cette envie
mais ouais un moment j'ai pensé au plan
b mais l'ingérence que on y pense
toujours mine de rien parce que c'est un
métier tellement fragile moi c'était
avant jeu avant je voulais être
éducatrice
mais aujourd'hui je crois que j'ai envie
de de produire des projets j'ai envie de
décrire
j'ai pas envie forcément de jouer dans
les projets que je produirai mais je
sais pas j'ai envie d'accompagner des
projets en fait n'a de voir on va
terminer avec un questionnaire comme on
parlait beaucoup de casting puisque
votre personnage plus particulièrement
qui fait plein de casting la pauvre et
ça marche pas très bien
via les votes dans le film quel est
votre pire souvenir de casting à traiter
dans mon tout premier casting j'ai eu de
la chance c'était pour le film sheitan
kim chapiron de kim chapiron est en fait
je devais faire une impro et on m'a
demandé je devais me faire draguer
pendant un pro et réagir de manière très
timide sauf que ce que kim ne savait pas
c'est que c'était là une premier casting
de toute ma vie
donc forcément j'étais rouge comme une
tomate certes intérieurement était dans
un état extrême tout la gérer c'était
horrible
le film donc dans lequel vous ne jouez
pas pour lequel vous auriez rêvé passé
le casting lula dans sailor et lula
vous avez déjà fait quelque chose de fou
pour obtenir un rôle y en a qui sera
serge et griffé déjà j'ai tué quelqu'un
je suis galère ça c'est forcément je
sais qu'il ya des acteurs qui sont prêts
à se battre qu'ils vont se battre et
c'est tout à leur honneur
mais moi je ne pense pas que ce métier
soit liée à une bataille
et si ça l'est c'est avec soin merci
merci à vous